for years it's been a familiar rallying
cry after scenes of police brutality and
deaths in police custody in the US but
with the killing of George Floyd an
unarmed black man who died after a
police officer kneeled on his neck for
nine minutes another slogan has come
into focus
[Music]
thousands of protesters are now calling
for money to be taken away from police
budgets and some even want to get rid of
the police entirely as we know it but
what does that actually mean and cancer
sighs we've run without an active police
force keeping things in check domestic
abuse mental health approach the
peripheral and drug abuse these are the
sorts of problems that law enforcement
are regularly called to deal with and
the police use up a lot of taxpayer
money so what are the alternatives one
idea is to take money away from the
police and redirect it into local
communities that means less money for
the police and more money for things
like health care housing and mental
health provisions supporters say the
more you put into communities the less
you need to police them this wouldn't
mean taking away all the money that goes
into the police but it would mean more
money going directly into the
communities that are most policed using
policing to respond to all of our
problems has become very normalized and
so to the point where we can't even
imagine how else one would deal with the
situation
and we say define it we mean the funds
we use to pay for our citizens to be
over policed we need to ship those funds
to affordable housing for early
childhood education things that actually
contribute to public safety many calling
for reform want to integrate the way the
police and social services work dallas
has reduced arrests in certain areas by
sending a social worker and a paramedic
along with police officers who respond
to mental health calls the city now has
fewer patients in hospital emergency
rooms not all activists agree on what
defunding means some simply want to take
money from police and put it into the
community some want to dismantle broken
police forces and replace them with more
accountable officers and some want to
abolish the police altogether
Camden in New Jersey was once listed the
most dangerous city in the u.s. in 2013
the city overhauled its police force and
hired hundreds more officers who were
trained to introduce themselves to
residents in person by knocking on doors
the murder rate has now gone down by 95
percent over the last seven years
some residents would still like to see
more black officers but the city has
come a long way with the right one so
look I'm not called for dismantling Rd
funny what I will say is that people who
call for it are making a valid case for
serious transformation as to how we
deliver safety and security they're not
talking about
over the past four decades the cost of
leasing has tripled to one hundred and
twenty two billion dollars after
inflation and it continues to rise while
prisons cost about ninety six billion
dollars a year
contrast that with national funding for
substance abuse and mental health
programs which is just five point seven
billion dollars a year President Trump
has rejected protesters calls for
defunding or disbanding branding himself
the law-and-order president and reducing
the problems in US police forces to a
few bad apples if they want to get rid
of the police forces actually want to
get rid of it we have to go the opposite
way we must invest more energy and
resources and police trainings we have
to respect our police we have to take
care of our police a high profile
Democrats have also distanced themselves
from the more radical cause for
disbanding while proposing sweeping
changes this is an inflection moment
Americanism woman where we must make
substance changes now changes the
American police as police is long
overdue campaign group eight can't wait
has recently published eight
recommendations for reforming the police
they would require officers to warn
people before shooting banning shooting
at moving vehicles and officers would
have to report each time they point a
gun at a citizen I'm not sure about the
abolishing the police we do need
protection I think is if we can read out
the bad
and keep my bring in the good the
I prefer that I'm not sure that that's
even the race gravity I think it could
cost more to police properly than it
costs to police improperly u.s. police
forces have been accused of brutality
and racism for years and there has been
outrage and anger each time another
black person has died in police custody
but George Floyd's death marks a turning
point 57 percent of Americans now think
the police are more likely to use
excessive force on black people that's
compared to just 34 percent in 2016 in
the wake of George Floyd's death 11
cities have banned chokehold and more
have promised change but will it be
dramatic enough for those demanding
reform many people who saw George
Floyd's death think holding a small
number of officers accountable is not
enough they want lasting change to come
of it
you